So we've covered all different
types of monetization models
from freemium to premium.
Which do you think is the best?
>> Well, premium was the easiest to do,
but most games have a free
option because it encourages more people
to try out the game in the first place.
We also learned about how
freemium games make money.
>> Yeah, I like learning about
the different types of ads.
And also learning how to code them into
a game using the Amazon mobile apps API.
What did you think was
the most interesting?
>> I thought learning about in app
purchases was great, because it went
into the details, like the importance
of being clear about value.
>> And we also mentioned
alternate ways to monetize.
Like through Amazon Underground and
outside your game by making and
selling merchandise.
>> Now that we've learned
about all these strategies,
what are our next steps?
I'd say,
we're almost ready to publish your game.
>> In our next lesson,
will show you the best practices for
testing out your game and publishing it.